I like the concept of Tenacious D and
what I like about it is I was watching
your video last night of the song you
guys wrote about Roadies you know yeah
yeah the video is hysterical because
this guy they're auditioning people for
a roadie job and the first guy walks in
and he's got every accoutrement that a
roadie would have he's got he's got the
the beard tied up with Band-Aid with the
rubber bands and he's got an all-black
outfit right and they go you know we're
gonna hire this guy We're Not Gonna
interview any more Roadies and it's uh
it's this great song but the music I
feel has gotten more sophisticated with
you guys it has we've taken it to a
deeper level I think thank you for
noticing Yeah well yeah because I I feel
to me Tenacious D was more of a joke in
the beginning like I know you guys were
having a rock star fantasy with it but
it came off to me as more of a joke this
album feels like more of an album Like
Music you know when we when we came out
with our first album we were kind of the
only joke band going right but now the
landscape has changed and there's some
great joke bands The Lonely Island Boys
from Saturday Night Live have incredible
songs incredibly funny songs and the
Flight of the Concords you know I don't
know if you saw their show they they so
there's a lot more competition so we had
to take it up a notch and the only way
we could compete with him was to take it
more seriously where are you guys at
musically now anyway in terms of your
own taste is there anybody I know that
the guy from the Foo Fighters Dave Grohl
yes is on your album plays drums yes
which is a great honor because he was
the drummer in Nirvana he's the greatest
drummer alive he is that's what that's
the coup how did we get out of this joke
band get is he on every is he on every
track yeah and he's uh how did you get
him did you he's just down with the D he
he saw us before we were big you know we
were playing at The Viper Room and
he's just a huge fan of music so what
what are your musical influences at the
top of my list I would probably put
Zeppelin who else do you like if I'm
going to be honest right there was a
period of Billy Joel in there why is
that what's wrong with Billy Joel he's
one of the greatest artists of all time
okay good true there you go well yeah I
mean it's not all Heavy yeah I mean this
guy's a great songwriter well okay but
come on Kyle back me up here well there
was that this is probably a little
cheesy yeah okay yeah they were a big
influence on me
I'd rather be a blue collar man
I'd like yes but I loved yes yes this is
great yes they were the masters of their
instruments ever no one could touch them
for musicianship right they were all
like Master Class Juilliard trained
right but I remember my big turnaround
was Ozzy Osbourne when I got blizzard of
Oz that's what changed the story for me
that's when I tapped into the heart
because Tenacious D is but Tenacious D
is a really hardcore Rock I mean it's
but it the music is solid thank you
oh